all right finally today anyone hoping to  start off 2021 as a multi-millionaire  has  two shots this week look at this these  were the lines we saw yesterday at the  lotto  store in prim look at that people waited  more than 90 minutes for a shot at a  winning  ticket tonight's mega millions jackpot  is 432 million dollars  tomorrow's powerball drawing is worth  410 million  both are among the 30 biggest lotto  jackpots in u.s history  and we asked people in line there what  they would do with all that money  my life is going to be changed my whole  family changed my friend change  i would invest and i would help people  in vegas that need help as well  and help out vegas to get our economy  back  and the odds of a single lotto ticket  hitting it's worse than one in 290  million but good luck everybody we'll  see tomorrow